[Música]
hola o bienvenidos a migrantes el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo los saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
en los últimos días la situación
migratoria en la frontera entre belarús
y polonia acaparó los titulares de los
medios en el mundo y es que hasta siete
mil personas según minsk esperaron en el
lado bielorruso para poder cruzar hacia
territorio de la unión europea el
tránsito por la ruta que no es nueva
incremento en las últimas semanas y se
agudizó ante la llegada del invierno que
amenaza a los cientos varados en el
límite europa acusa a belarús de usar a
los migrantes como un arma de presión
por las sanciones impuestas contra el
gobierno mientras la atención se
mantiene en el plano político la
situación humanitaria parece ser una
cuestión pendiente veamos algunos
testimonios en el siguiente informe
a sólo semanas de dar a luz esta iraquí
de 26 años llegó con su esposo y tres
hijas a polonia antes de lograrlo seis
de sus intentos por cruzar hacia el país
fueron frustrados por las autoridades
y estos han sido los dos meses más
agotadores de mi vida incluso nos
metimos en un estanque el agua me llegó
hasta aquí me caí y no teníamos ropa
después de eso me enferme ahí fue cuando
los guardias nos atraparon en la
frontera
en menos de un mes dar a luz y espera
poder hacerlo en alemania su destino
final donde planea darle un mejor futuro
a su familia anfac que le hemos visto
opresión en irak peor y más grave que
esta opresión ya tenemos una meta que
alcanzar incluso si regresamos al
principio tenemos que lograr la meta de
una vida mejor
ella dice que todo vale la pena con tal
de alejarse de irak pero es un
sentimiento que no comparten algunos de
sus compatriotas que lamentan el viaje
también en polonia pero lejos de la
tensión de la frontera hay personas que
esperan que sus familiares logren pasar
hacia territorio comunitario abu llegó a
europa en 2014 y ahora vive en suecia
está preocupado porque su hija tomó la
ruta hacia europa sin consultárselo
ahora está bloqueada en belarús y
me dice estoy muerta no tengo emoción
soy una persona muerta ella está aquí a
40 kilómetros y están jugando con ellos
su hija completa un mes en la frontera y
lo poco que sabe de ella es que ha
pasado hambre sed está enferma y no
puede caminar que los gobernantes pongan
fin a este asunto están jugando unos
contra otros de un lado a otro y quién
es el combustible esta pobre gente
shalit comparte la angustia que vive abu
este sirio espera a su padre que se
quedó solo después de que a su madre se
le permitiera quedarse en polonia en uno
de sus intentos por cruzar la frontera
normalmente deberían haber ido al
hospital juntos pero hasta el día de hoy
no sabemos por qué los separaron nos
dijeron que mi madre estaba en el
hospital y mi padre en una comisaría o
la situación humanitaria en la frontera
entre polonia y belarús es preocupante y
la ruta no dejará de ser camino para
miles de personas que buscan llegar a la
unión europea'
y mientras la crisis migratoria está a
las puertas de europa familias lejos de
la frontera entre polón y belarús
esperan noticias de sus seres queridos
muchos de los que emigraron durante el
verano son kurdos del norte de jac
allí la crisis económica y los bloqueos
a la libertad de expresión empujan a los
habitantes a irse varios de ellos
murieron en el tránsito un equipo de
france 24 viajó hasta irak donde se vive
la otra cara de la crisis migratoria
en un cementerio en el norte de irak
cada palabra de tierras recubre el
cuerpo de gaitán un joven kurdo de 25
años que murió en la frontera con
polonia hace dos semanas sus restos
acaban de ser devueltos a su familia
todavía en estado de shock y no había
comido en cinco días era diabético pero
no tenía su medicación los guardias
fronterizos sabían que estaba enfermo
las fuerzas armadas polacas no quisieron
escuchar nada y enviaron el cuerpo sin
vida de gaira de regreso al lado
bielorruso según su familia su dolor es
inmenso su vida también
lo hicieron de una manera tan
dictatorial y poco ética murió en suelo
polaco pero se lo llevaron y lo enviaron
de regreso a otro lado de la frontera
todo fue tan brutal
al igual que caerán al menos una docena
de personas más han muerto a las puertas
de europa en las últimas semanas otros
están atrapados en una tierra de nadie y
tienen que hacer frente al frío al
hambre la sed sin embargo muchos kurdos
siguen decididos a irse estos cursos
huyen de la crisis económica y los
excesos autoritarios de poder seco de 22
años es de los que se alistan para salir
hoy nos invita a su casa para mostrarnos
sus cosas que caben en esta bolsita and
find down este suéter es muy abrigado es
genial para viajar de lo contrario tengo
calcetines un cargador a mano checo
consiguió su visa hace unos días gracias
a un intermediario contactado en un
grupo de telegram quien le pidió cinco
mil dólares incluido el vuelo y cinco
noches de hotel había dado a cádiz son
grupos de apoyo aquí preguntas lo que
quieras envías tu pregunta y alguien te
contactará directamente por mensaje
privado el viaje se ha complicado en los
últimos días porque turquía ha bloqueado
los vuelos de los iraquíes a minsk pero
llegó no pierde la esperanza de
encontrar otras rutas posibles a través
de catar o los emiratos árabes
mientras algunos migrantes en la
frontera fueron repatriados a irak otros
esperan en refugios en belarús minsk y
bruselas no llegan a un acuerdo para dar
solución a la crisis y el invierno
amenaza a los que permanecen bloqueados
en la región hasta aquí inmigrantes de
france 24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes efe 24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]